(bass noise)
- The US and China are fighting a war.
It's not a war that you can really see
and it's not a traditional
battlefield war with soldiers,
at least not yet.
This is a war that's being
fought in government offices
and company boardrooms.
It's a war that's being fought
with rules and regulations
and it's meant to stop rivals
from getting their hands
on the most important technology
in the world, microchips.
You might hear them called semiconductors,
microchips, or integrated circuits.
These are all the same thing.
We're just gonna call
them chips, microchips,
tiny pieces of metal that are
magic and that run our world.
(upbeat music)
This is a big thing that's happening
in geopolitics right now
and I wanna help you understand the stakes
of this new conflict
between the US and China.
It's gonna be the center
of global attention
for years to come.
What we're seeing right now is
how boring trade regulations
and business rules can
escalate to something
that can impact your everyday life
because your life depends on chips,
whether you know it or not.
In fact, let me show you.
- Everything has silicon in it.
Anything that has any
technological smartness
to it is a product of silicon.
(upbeat music)
- Sorry, Tom.
- Oh, and it's not just
like the usual suspects,
techie things, yep, microchip.
- My refrigerator, silicon,
my microwave, silicon.
Nah, I'm just playing with you.
This doesn't have silicon in it.
(upbeat music)
This is just a few little things
I found around the office,
but like silicon is in your
refrigerator, your microwave,
like it is in your digital clock.
It is what makes our world go round.
I mean, we are speaking
through silicon right now.
Like you are watching this on the internet
that is made possible because
of silicon on a screen
that is being fired by a silicon chip,
like everything is silicon in our world,
besides like the forest or
something, or analog cameras.
So microchips make our economy possible,
but it's not just tech, it's
not just the consumer tech.
It's also military, the
military needs microchips.
(upbeat music)
They need microchips for weapons systems.
They need microchips for intelligence.
They need microchips for AI.
They need microchips to
stay ahead of their rivals.
Microchips represent geopolitical power
because they represent military power.
That's something to just
keep in mind as we go
through this story.
- House of Representatives Nancy Pelosi
is in Taiwan tonight, China
is already responding.
- [Speaker] Lead the world
in future industries,
protect our national security.
- We're in the middle of one
of the most fundamental changes
in the character of war,
in the history of mankind.
- Hey, pause.
I feel really strongly that
the internet is a place
where you can learn to level
up your professional skills.
I learned all my skills on the internet.
That is how I know how to
animate and edit and film
and do all of these things.
The sponsor of today's
video also believes this.
Thank you Scaler for
sponsoring today's video.
Scaler is a place where you
can go and level up your skills
as a programmer or engineer.
Scaler is a short term
accelerator program.
It's like eight to 11
months and it's meant
to enhance the coding skills
of software professionals,
basically make you way
better at your job and then
to help you get a better job.
A big part of the Scaler program is
to hack the job recruitment process,
to make you better interviews,
to get you in the right doors
so that you can get better skills
and then a better job in this industry.
In addition to their curated
computer science course,
they offer one-on-one mentorships
with software professionals
who are like on the front lines
of this industry, they give you referrals.
It really is just like a one-stop shop
if you want to level up as
a software professional.
If you like me,
have a career in a very quickly changing,
technology-based field,
you know that things
are always leveling up.
And the best way to stay on
the front lines is a program
like Scaler that will accelerate you,
that will help you get in the right doors
and that will give you
the skills that you need
to stay on the cutting
edge of all of this stuff.
I am a giant proponent,
like philosophically,
of the idea that you can
bypass big institutions
where education is usually done and learn
to level up your skills on the internet,
like a giant fan, it's
like a principle for me.
And that's what Scaler is doing here.
They're giving you access
to level up your skills
to become a better equipped
software professional
and then to go get the job
that you want in this industry.
So if you are a software
professional who's ready
to grow their skills,
Scaler is the place for you.
There is a link in my description.
Clicking that link gets you
in on a free live webinar
where you can go get a flavor for this.
Trust me, your career will thank you.
Thank you Scaler for
sponsoring today's video.
Let's dive back into microchips.
(robotic noise)
- In 1959, the US was
about to get very lucky.
Computers at the time
were becoming a thing,
but they kind of looked like this.
Tons of wires connecting everything,
all of them sending little
precise electronic signals
to each other to solve
tedious, complex math problems.
It was clunky, it was inefficient,
it wasn't very special yet.
But then two American engineers
that were working separately
at two totally different
companies had a very similar idea.
And the idea was to get rid
of this, all these wires.
There was this new technology
that had cropped up
called a transistor.
It was like a really precise,
reliable on and off switch,
allows you to control pulses
of electricity super precisely.
But at first transistors looked like this.
They were big and clunky, lots of parts.
So the idea was what if we
start carving these little on
and off switches onto a
material called silicon.
It's like a super abundant
metal like material inside
of Earth's crust,
but it's actually a horrible
conductor of electricity.
If you mix silicon with other elements,
it conducts electricity really well.
It is a semiconductor of electricity,
exactly what they needed to
precisely control the flow
of electricity very accurately,
no more clunky long wires.
Let's just carve our
little transistor switches
onto this silicon chip, a single circuit,
that way we can fit a
lot more into one place,
all close together, so
that's what they did.
And then the world changed forever.
- [Narrator] With the
transistor, man has gone far
toward matching some of the
capacity of the human brain.
- Okay, real quick aside here,
we're gonna get to the
geopolitics and stuff,
but I was so curious about one thing.
Why does being able to
precisely control the on
and off switch or like
the flow of electricity,
do anything to change the world?
Well, it turns out,
this is where my mind bends a little bit.
Just stick with me here.
So transistors can turn on
and off and they send a signal
that results in one of two
things, a one or a zero
when it gets to the other side,
super boring and useless if you
just have one little transistor
sending a one or a zero.
But if you have a thousand
of these switches,
all sending little signals
in the right order,
suddenly you have something that kind
of resembles a little brain,
firing signals in a coordinated system
that can actually solve
logical mathematical problems
and literally remember things.
This is kind of how our brain works.
It's pulses, lots of pulses.
And now we're talking about computing.
This is how computers work.
(upbeat music)
- [Speaker] The first light.
- The more pulses of
electricity you can control,
the more you can do with technology.
And suddenly there's a new
gold rush in the United States,
but the gold is now silicon.
And the rush is to put as
many of these little switches
onto that silicon chip as possible
so that we can make our technology do more
and more sophisticated stuff.
And now people have smarter
clocks and TVs and radios
and video games and calculators,
things that you can hold in
your hand and press a bunch
of buttons and suddenly the silicon chip
is solving math problems
for you instantaneously.
What is happening?
This is magic.
Oh, and it's not just
tech bros in the sixties
who are loving this,
the US military and NASA are first in line
to get their hands on these new chips.
They dream of using them for
more sophisticated weapons
or going to the moon.
Chips were becoming a
currency for national power.
We gotta protect them, thanks to the USA,
luckily the USA didn't
really have to do much
to protect them at first,
they were killing it.
They were the global leaders
of this chip making stuff.
Every year US companies crammed
more and more transistors
onto this little piece of silicon,
more calculations per second.
More and more companies
are now cropping up
to make dreams come true with
their new magical microchips.
Lots of this action was
happening right here
in central California in a
valley that would soon take
on the name of the material
that enabled all this magic to happen.
By the mid 1980s,
they were carving nearly 300,000
little on and off switches
onto a piece of silicon.
Oh, and look, it's Steve
Jobs and Bill Gates.
- Yes.
- They're using these
more sophisticated silicon
chips to change the course
of history, home computing,
color televisions,
more advanced satellites, and smaller
and smaller electronic
devices of all kinds.
There's a revolution happening.
And over the next 30 years,
the number of transistors
that they can fit onto a piece
of silicon starts to become ridiculous.
And it's like the nineties
and these things are
getting faster and smaller.
And now humans have
computers in their homes
that are more advanced than
the ones that were used
to land on the moon.
- Not only do they play
the typical computer games
that all the kids enjoy,
but their curiosity for
learning has skyrocketed.
- And look, it's even smaller
now, it fits in your pocket.
And we are calling it iPhone.
(crows cheers)
- None of this is possible
without these little magical
brains made of silicon.
Okay, but then a problem arises
and it has to do with these,
these look like just factories
where they make microchips, right?
No, these are not just factories.
We have a special name for these.
They're called FABS and they're
a central part of this story
because listen,
cramming tens of millions
of transistors onto a piece
of metal-like substance
from the earth is hard
to begin with.
But as the number of transistors continues
to double and double and double,
making them becomes
incredibly complicated.
I mean, look at these operations.
This is inside of a FAB.
And the reason why it looks
like they're doing open
heart surgery here is
because even a single speck of
dust that gets into this FAB
and onto one of these
chips can totally ruin it.
So yeah,
it was American companies
who are designing
and making chips,
but every year they have
to spend more and more
on these tedious FABS,
these factories on steroids.
They're getting really spendy,
like billions of dollars spendy.
Meanwhile an ocean away,
you've got a couple of economic
miracles happening in all
of these countries in East Asia
that are rapidly developing
and they want in on this
microchip gold rush.
(upbeat music)
One of these countries is Japan,
where a bunch of new tech
companies were getting really good
at making chips and they
could make them and sell them
for way cheaper than the US.
Oh, and by the way,
this was with the help of
the Japanese government
who's like subsidizing this,
governments love microchips.
That's gonna be a theme in this video.
(upbeat music)
The US is hating this.
They're kind of freaking
out that Japan is getting in
on all the chip gold rush, they
gotta do something about it.
So it's 1987 and the US
government basically says,
no more Japanese chips.
They put a 100% tax on Japanese
chips coming into the US,
which not surprisingly just
crushes Japan's chip industry.
Too bad, so sad, Japan, said
the President at the time
who was, wait, what the
hell, Ronald Reagan?
The profit of free markets and free trade?
Well, what's going on here?
- Our aim is to increase
our national wealth
so all will have more.
- Well, turns out that
chips are really important,
so important in fact that
Mr. free market economics
abandoned his principles
to protect American chips.
This is a theme, we're
gonna see a lot more of it.
Okay, so let's move on.
Meanwhile,
another Asian economic miracle
country is growing super fast
and wants to get in on this,
but they also are looking
over at Japan and they're like,
we don't want the US
to squash us for trying
to compete with them.
So if we can't beat 'em, let's join 'em.
(upbeat music)
Oh, and this is an really
important foreshadow here.
Taiwan is looking over here
at their neighbor China,
who's also getting really
rich and more serious
about making good on
their lifelong promise
to eventually invade Taiwan and quote,
"Reunite it with China."
Kind of scary.
So in the back of Taiwan's mind,
they're also kind of looking
for a way to get the West
to protect them, so they made a bet,
a freaking brilliant bet
that solved all their problems at once.
At the time,
a bunch of engineers in Taiwan
were actually leaving Taiwan
to go to the US to go to a
university there and then
to actually work for US companies
in the cutting edge microchip economy,
Texas Instruments, Intel.
So the first thing the
Taiwanese government does
is lure them back, they
guarantee them jobs.
They pay for their travel costs,
they give them tax breaks
to create companies.
Their goal is to create a
Silicon Valley in Taiwan
and it totally works, it's
like a reverse brain drain.
Thousands of engineers returned
to Taiwan to start companies
and to help build the
microchip industry in Taiwan.
And one of those engineers is the one
who actually changed the game,
this guy named Morris Chang,
he had the best idea of all of them.
He had seen that American
chip makers were hating
how much money they had
to invest in these FABS,
these really complicated
factories to make microchips.
His idea was instead of trying to compete
with the United States
in the chip industry
and get crushed like Japan
did, let's become their friend.
Let's solve their problem.
We won't design chips,
we won't make devices,
we won't make the software.
We will just make the chips themselves.
We will become the masters of FABS,
the tedious expensive job of getting more
and more transistors
onto a piece of silicon.
So he starts a company called
Taiwan's Semiconductor
Manufacturing Company, TSMC,
super promising and creative name, Morris.
And the government of
Taiwan is super into it
because now they can get
in on the chip gold rush
and instead of pissing
off the United States,
they actually will solve the
US' problem and crucially,
make the US reliant on them,
so now they have protection,
a silicon shield to protect them
from their big aggressive neighbor.
The government gave nearly
half of the startup cost
to Morris Chang to start this new venture.
They connected him to venture capital
and according to Chang himself,
the Prime Minister of Taiwan even called
a super rich Taiwanese
investor to force him
to invest in TSMC.
Whoa, okay, yeah, wow.
Like you can see just how vital chips are,
a little piece of silicon with a bunch
of on and off switches.
TSMC was basically a state-owned
company from the beginning.
So yeah,
Taiwan's now in the
game and semiconductors
are now becoming a geopolitical
bargaining chip, chip,
a geopolitical bargaining chip.
I kind of regret it, sorry.
(upbeat music)
- Go in here.
- I believe I'm going to be the nominee.
- So it's like the early 2000s
and semiconductors are now
squarely a part of geopolitics.
But meanwhile, in business
world in Silicon Valley,
they're loving this Taiwan
situation because now instead
of having to do all of this
expensive, tedious FAB stuff,
they can just do the
design and the software
and the business side of it
and they can just ship it off
to TSMC and they do the rest,
taking on the expensive,
tedious work of maintaining
their FABS and keeping them up
to the cutting edge,
which requires billions
of dollars every year.
Like to keep some perspective,
look at this graph.
This is the number of transistors
on a piece of silicon.
By 2010,
they're now getting a billion
transistors onto a piece
of silicon the size of your fingernail.
And the only way to do
that is to make each one
of these insanely small.
So let's just take a moment
to blow our own minds here.
Each transistor is becoming
smaller than a width
of a human hair, wait, no, sorry,
that's actually way too big of a scale.
A human hair is like
90,000 nanometers thick.
We need to go smaller
like a red blood cell.
Wait, no, that's still too big.
7,000 nanometers, okay, a virus,
something that's not even
totally alive, it's so small.
Wait, that's 14 nanometers, still too big.
I mean we are getting
into insane scales here.
IBM recently revealed the chip
with transistors that
are two nanometers thick,
making them literally
smaller than a strand of DNA.
So in these FABS,
the reason it looks like
this is because they have
to figure out how to do
this and to keep doing it
and keep making it smaller and smaller,
providing the world with
the most advanced chips.
And this is why we have nice things.
Your entire world revolves
around what is happening
on these little strips of silicon.
(upbeat music)
- But more and more US chip companies
don't actually have FABS.
They design them,
they do all the software and
the machinery and the selling
and the business,
but the actual making of
the chip happened in Taiwan.
But as 92% of all advanced
chips are now made in Taiwan,
what this means is that the
US is completely reliant
on TSMC basically.
And finally, we're
getting to the conflict.
This is where China becomes
really important because China,
the most populous country
is suddenly very rich
and they want new tech too.
So they become actually a giant
customer of all these chips,
buying 40% of all the chips in the world,
meaning that they are
now reliant on the US,
who is reliant on Taiwan to
design and make their chips.
So let's look at the modern chip industry
as it all comes together,
which is gonna set the stage
for how this conflict
is playing out today.
Here's a very simplified
version of the supply chain.
Again, very simplified, it's just insane.
I'm not gonna go into the full thing.
The US is the one that
manufactures the machines,
the software, and the designs.
Japan makes metals and
chemicals for chips.
The Netherlands makes this
crazy UV laser machine
that is used to carve the chips.
And Taiwan crucially does
the expensive tedious job
of actually making the chips.
Almost all of the most advanced
chips in the world are made
in Taiwan.
And then you have China,
who is the giant customer in all of this.
They're the ones who are
buying more and more chips
to grow their economy.
I mean, look at this
beautiful supply chain.
You've got a bunch of countries
that are involved now,
everyone has a part to
play and everyone depends
on each other for chips.
Globalization is great.
Economic interdependence is a recipe
for peace and mutual prosperity, right?
I mean it used to be.
But there's something else
happening with the supply chain
that might be hard to see in this diagram,
which is that the US is still
the kingpin of this system.
They're the most important player.
They have the most important
ingredients, the best designs,
the best software, and the
most machines to make chips.
Taiwan, their bestie,
has the second most important
ingredients in all of this,
the FABS that actually make the chips.
China on the other hand is
in a position of weakness.
Their role is basically the
big hungry chip consumer,
totally reliant on their frenemy,
the United States and their
annoying neighbor, Taiwan,
who they want to invade,
but now they're reliant
on for cutting edge chips.
And what's at stake here for China?
Well, it's not just their economy.
They don't want chips just
so they can have a bunch
of cool tech.
They want it because more and more,
they need advanced chips
for their military.
(upbeat music)
It's like the 2010s,
China's military is getting kind of scary,
but it's not that scary says
the IS, we're not that worried.
We'll always be ahead
of China when it comes
to controlling the supply chain.
And our military gets first
dibs on all the best chips.
China has no chance of catching up ever.
And this is true, China was truly behind.
They did not have the tech and
the designs and the companies
and the ability to make advanced chips.
They were reliant on the United States.
If China pissed off the US,
they could just take away their chips.
And now we have a rising
conflict on our hands.
(upbeat music)
China, this big superpower
is not gonna let this happen.
They realize that they
have to do two things.
Number one, they have to
start making their own chips.
They wanna break free and
stop relying on the US
for anything,
make their own chips so that
the US doesn't have leverage
over them.
And number two and deeply
related is they want to continue
to build up their
military, to modernize it,
to build more war ships and satellites
and high tech missiles and
drones and eventually AI.
All of this needs advanced
chips, which they don't have.
So they're like, we are
gonna make them on our own.
And the US is like, good luck
China, you're so far behind.
Good luck trying to figure
out how to do this thing
that we've spent the past 60
years figuring out how to do,
make really expensive chips.
Experts in software and
machinery and FABS like,
you have no chance.
So how is China gonna catch up?
Lucky for them, in China,
there's a blurry line between
businesses and the military.
It's all kind of overseen by the state
and also lucky for them,
there are loads of US tech
companies that are addicted
to making money by selling
microchip technology to China.
So instead of invent it themselves,
they see an opportunity here.
Need software and equipment
for your new chip industry?
Get it from the US.
Need fancy chip designs and software?
US companies have you covered.
Need those high-tech chips produced
for your military projects?
American companies will sell them to you.
And yes, TSMC in Taiwan
will make them for you.
Wait, China's using US
technology to get ahead
of US technology, what?
In 2021, the Washington Post reported
that China was building
super advanced laboratories
to test scary new weapons including nukes.
And guess what?
They were using American
semiconductor tech to do this.
It started to become clear
that American companies
were selling tech and chips and software
to Chinese tech companies that
were actually just a front
for the military.
Wow, yikes.
The US chip industry is now
allowing China to get ahead.
This was starting to happen,
but I think what really woke up the US
is when this happened.
- [Narrator] Huge step
forward in China's military.
China conducted two tests
of a hypersonic missile system,
technology that would allow it
to fire a nuclear warhead
faster than anyone else.
- The US does not
currently have the ability
to even track this weapon,
much less defeat it.
- US military generals wake up one morning
to discover that China has
just tested a new weapon,
a missile that flew
around the entire world,
going five times the speed
of sound, a mile a second.
Oh, and it's really hard to see
because it flies below radar range.
It's super nimble, maneuverable,
and has the ability to carry nukes.
The US had been working
on something similar,
but China beat them to it by years
and it was American microchip technology
that helped them build it.
Oh shit.
Yikes.
This totally caught them off guard.
- [Narrator] Says that US
intelligence services had no idea
that China was so far ahead.
- So turns out that while
the US government thought
that they were running faster
and that they were fine,
they were actually fueling the
rise of their biggest rival
by giving them the technology
that they need to get ahead.
So the US decides that
they've gotta do something.
China is ahead on these missiles
and they might get ahead
on things like AI and they're
doing it with our tech.
No more free trade, no more free markets.
The government is jumping
back into the chip game
to sort this out.
- Fundamental change
is taking place today,
politically, economically,
and technologically.
- All right, Joe Biden's
like rolling up his sleeves.
He's like, what do we do here?
Step one, cut 'em off,
no more chips for China.
- The Biden administration
published a large set
of export controls on Friday in order
to slow Beijing's technological
and military advances.
- [Speaker] Restrictions will
limit Chinese companies access
to advanced computer chip.
- And here we are, back in the
fun, bureaucratic paperwork,
Department of Commerce, Bureau
of Industry and Security,
docket number 220930-0204RIN0674...
"Certain advanced computing
and semiconductor manufacturing
items, supercomputers,
and semiconductor end use,
entity list modification."
We're not gonna go through this.
This is just a bunch of rules
that says no more chips to China.
All those cutting edge
chips that China was buying
from US companies, blocked.
- [Speaker] The restrictions
will limit Chinese companies
access to advanced computer chips.
- [Speaker] Manufacturing
equipment they need
to make their own chips?
Blocked.
All that US made vital software
that Chinese companies need
to design their own chips?
Blocked, blocked, blocked.
- We will bring these
jobs back to our shores
and end our dependence on foreign chips.
- All right.
- In fact,
the Biden administration
went super far to say
that any company globally
that uses US tech
to produce chips is now
blocked from doing business
with Chinese firms.
- [Speaker] To cut China off from
certain semiconductor chips made
anywhere in the world with US equipment.
- Why stop there?
Americans are now forbidden from working
for Chinese chip companies,
this is huge news.
Like this is huge news, this is happening.
This is like we're in the
middle of this right now.
But let's go back to that visual
of the whole supply chain.
If you cut off this, then
yeah, you hurt China,
but you also hurt the
other side of this line,
US chip makers.
Like one example, this
US chipmaker, Nvidia,
they went from selling
tons of chips to China
to suddenly being banned from doing so.
This has led to a $400
million loss in revenue
in just one quarter.
Poof, up in smoke.
One of the biggest chip
makers now totally cut off
from their big customer
because Joe Biden is afraid
of the Chinese military
and for good reason,
which leads to step two of this policy.
The Biden administration
wasn't gonna leave
these tech companies out dry.
So they gave billions of
dollars to American chip makers
to say, "Hey, yes, sorry we cut you off
from your main customer because
we're kind of getting scared
of their military,
but we have to protect our
chips, here's a bunch of money."
Congress passed the CHIPS Act,
which gives billions of
dollars to these companies
to create FABS back in the United States.
- This time it wasn't Russia
but China, another rival power
would get way ahead of us
if we didn't pull out all the stops.
And this legislation
is the first large step
in pulling out all of those stops.
- Government wants the
FABS to come home to ensure
that this most valuable
technology isn't solely reliant
on outside countries and
we're talking giant payouts.
50 billion taxpayer dollars
go to companies like Intel,
which is now opening a new FAB in Ohio.
- We are gonna build the most
advanced stuff in the world,
right here in Ohio.
- Or even TSMC themselves,
which is based in Taiwan,
but is now opening a new FAB in Arizona.
Keep it in the family.
Okay, so this is economic war
and the Biden administration
just did a huge move.
Reminder that the reason
why this is important is
because it's not just about
like business or even missiles.
This is about chips.
Chips are not just chips,
chips are the future.
Chips are power.
Yes, chips mean economic
growth and new cool technology,
but chips also mean new weapons.
Chips are the currency
of geopolitical power,
kind of like what oil used to be,
but now it's freaking silicon with a bunch
of on and off switches on it.
The US is taking control
of its valuable resource
and cutting China off.
So the US makes this big
move, cuts China off,
and this is geopolitical conflict.
They just made the move, the
ball's in China's court now.
How will they respond?
And this is where Taiwan
comes back into the picture.
(upbeat music)
Taiwan is this small
country that finds itself
in the crossfires of this conflict.
92% of all advanced chips
are made here mostly by TSMC.
The US is totally reliant on them.
A few months before the Biden
administration was doing all
of this, making it illegal
to sell chips to China,
Congresswoman Nancy Pelosi visited Taiwan,
not just to like shake hands
with political leaders, no,
she was there to visit TSMC, the chip FAB.
What Pelosi was really doing
here was signaling to Taiwan
that they are vital to American security.
US relies on this and will protect it.
- Came to Taiwan to make
unequivocally clear,
we'll not abandon our commitment
to Taiwan and we are proud
of our enduring friendship.
- And in doing so,
she shows us what China's
counter move might be
in all of this, it might be Taiwan.
- Are you willing to
get involved militarily
to defend Taiwan if it comes to that?
- Yes, that's a commitment we made.
- Okay, but wait,
what this doesn't mean is like
China's gonna invade Taiwan
and like take all the chips
or like take over the FAB
or something, that that
scenario doesn't make any sense.
If China invaded Taiwan,
all they would find is
a bunch of empty FABS
if they weren't bombed already.
They wouldn't know how to operate them.
They wouldn't have all of the
engineers and the software
and all of the supply chain
stuff that they would need
to actually make chips.
They would likely be fighting a war
and the US would probably get involved.
I made a whole video about
it, you can go check it out.
Anyway,
the effective counter move
here for China would be
to operate right on the
edge of active warfare
to strike back at the US
without provoking a military response.
This is how big nuclear powers do it.
They don't actually clash.
They want to just sort
of poke at each other.
One scenario would be
China sending a bunch
of its navy ships to set up in
the ocean right around here,
creating a kind of partial blockade.
They could stop cargo
ships that are coming
to and from the island,
kind of just slowing everything down,
but really holding the silicon hostage,
making it hard for the supply
chain to actually work.
I mean just remember like
the Covid 19 chip shortage
or like supply chain shortage
or even like the Suez Canal blockage
from a couple years ago.
Imagine those supply chain
issues, but like on steroids,
totally debilitating and being
used for a hostile purpose
to strike back at the US.
Like Biden forbidding American companies
to sell chips to China,
the blockade would be a way to strike
at your nuclear armed rival
without going too far,
without risking too much
escalation or a miscalculation.
- [Speaker] It's incumbent
upon us to stay number one.
- [Speaker] To lead the
world in future industries,
protect our national security.
- [Speaker] We are gonna build the most
advanced stuff in the world.
- That's where we're at.
We're in the middle of
another economic war
between big nuclear powers.
We don't know what happens next,
but one thing that feels clear
to me is that Cold War vibes
are back as these two great
powers with different ideologies
about the world compete with each other.
This fight over chips will continue.
And this idea in international
relations that I kind of took
for granted,
which is that like globalization
and interdependence is good
and will lead to less conflict,
it's being seriously challenged.
Economic interdependence
is being used as a weapon.
That's what we're seeing
here and not just here.
I made a video a couple months ago
about how Vladimir Putin
is cutting off natural gas
to Europe, frankly,
it's not that much different
than Joe Biden cutting
off microchips to China.
I mean it is different in a
lot of ways, blah, blah, blah,
we get it.
But like the the big mechanics
of how this conflict is playing out,
it's peculiar and and is becoming a part
of how conflict looks today.
So even as this old
school style war continues
to rage in Ukraine,
we're seeing an evolution
of how conflict works
in our world.
Where once a lot of conflict revolved
around natural resources
like oil, most recently,
the currency of power.
We've moved to an era
where a magical piece
of metal-like substance called silicon,
pulsing ones and zeros,
is kind of the new oil,
the new currency of power,
the new thing that we should protect
to protect our military supremacy.
So in a big shift of the
trend of globalization,
countries are now turning
inward to protect their stuff,
leading to a new era of
distrust, severed connection,
and rising tensions.
Okay.
Okay, okay, semiconductors is over.
That's it, I'm now going to
eat a Reese's peanut buttercup
from Trader Joe's.
Mm, wow that's good.
I love this thing.
Okay, that's the end of the video.
Thanks to Scaler one more time
for sponsoring this video.
There's link in the
description that gets you
on a free class if you wanna try that out.
I have a couple things
I wanna tell you about.
Thanks for watching.
I like to speak into a
microphone at the end
because it makes me feel
like I'm a podcaster.
Should I start a podcast?
People are asking me to start a podcast.
What should I talk about on my podcast?
Anyway, thanks for watching everyone.
So we should probably
talk about the Newsroom.
So we make a video, an
extra video every month.
It's a behind the scenes
vlog where we like capture
how all of this is made,
there's a big team of people,
lots of cool fun personalities,
lots of very skilled people
who touch these videos.
I'm just like one cog in the machine.
That video goes live every
month and it's available
to people who are members of the Newsroom,
which is what we call our Patreon.
I just like to call it the
Newsroom 'cause it's like cooler.
On the Newsroom, you also
get access to my scripts,
which are like big things that if maybe
if you're like a journalist
or a video storyteller,
could be useful for you.
You also get access to Tom Fox tracks.
Tom Fox is our composer.
You get royalty free music
that you can use in your videos
if you are a member of the Newsroom
and you get the warm fuzzy feeling
of supporting independent journalism.
So the newsroom is over on
patreon.com/JohnnyHarris.
Another thing that I should
mention is that we have LUTs
and presets, which are like
a thing that you can buy
and then you can color
your video or your photos
in the way that we color it.
We worked with the professional colorist
to develop these things.
They're basically presets and
they are for photo and video
and they look really nice
because I like things
to look nice.
And welcome to all the
new subscribers here.
There's been a lot of new people
around the channel lately,
and it's fun to have this community grow.
So I'm gonna keep telling
stories and being curious
and learning and looking
for evidence and data
and questioning my assumptions
and I appreciate you all being here.
So I'll see you in the next one, bye.
(upbeat music)